eliminating a set of pawns this position
it's a dead draw
but the time situation and now there's
just no way that he's just going to move
his rook he can pre-move this now
rook to the dark squares and that's it
yeah
napoleon actually has no way to break
through the black defenses
black's rook just sitting on those two
squares two protected squares
white has no way to break through 26
seconds it should be enough for rajab
oh okay and uh that's it as a draw
rajapov is through
and timor rajavo is the winner of the
quarter-final match against janna
pomnyacci and will
faze daniel dubo in the semi-finals
starting tomorrow
wow the man who had retired from chess
is back he's through and i think we saw
napoli actually throw something there he
reacted
very badly that's because he didn't
realize the position repeated himself
three times
before the draw um yeah rajabov he
deserves to go through
nerves of steel but and there he is back
with oh
we have some anger wow he's so angry
he's angry because he knows he could
have actually continued for another 50
moves to try and win on time he could
have just kept putting his king on
different squares
put his bishops on different bishop on
different squares every time he could
have at least tried to win on the clock
yes he exactly because he had some extra
time he had at least 20 seconds
extra and and actually team